l'essentiel de l'actualité locale de ce
21 janvier avec la grève au dépôt de
cigarettes qui fournit les buralistes
d'île-de-fance levé les livraisons de
tabac qui reprennent certains
établissements n'étaient plus en mesure
de répondre aux demandes des
consommateurs lire à voix haute devant
un public une phobie pour certains à
bois d'arcil miaatek propose de dépasser
ses appréhensions avec des ateliers
demain mercredi soirée hommage au 50e
anniversaire du premier concert des
beitatles en France c'était à
Versailles les buralistes vont pouvoir
enflouer progressivement leurs étales
lundi le piquet de greffe qui bloquait
le dépôt de logiste à France depuis le
10 janvier a été levé ce site basé en
Scine et Marne est le principal
fournisseur des buralistes
d'Île-de-France si certains bureaux de
tabac ont été réapprovisionnés dès mardi
d'autres comme ce buraliste de Montini
devront encore patienter avant que les
livraisons ne reprennent leur rythme
habituel dans cet autre bureau de tabac
les étales sont plus remplis le gérant
est allé directement dans un dépôt du
centre de la France à 300 km malgré les
craintes de braquage moi quand c'est mon
mari qui va chercher le dépannage
j'avoue que je ne vis pas tant qu'il est
parvenu et NOTAM demain il retournera
puisque on est déjà en manque et il faut
prévoir encore pour 15 jours 15 jours
avant la prochaine livraison malgré la
levée du piquet de grève les salariés de
logiste à France de leur côté
poursuivent les négociations pour une
revalorisation
salariale près de 60 % des internautes
comptent profiter des soldes sur
internet un chiffre en Haus selon la
dernière étude de la Fédération du
e-commerce et de la vente à distance la
sociétéelinoise iGraal propose du
cashback c'est-à-dire un pourcentage du
prix payé qui revient à l'acheteur elle
travaille avec 1400 commerçants en ligne
et avec les soldes divivers tous les
records en terme de vente ont été battus
c'est impressionnant en janvier on est
au-delà de nos espérances donc il se
passe quelque chose alors peut-être que
c'est dû à la notoriété d'igral qui est
croissante mais sans doute que encore
plus c'est les consommateurs ont ancré
dans leurs habitudes
d'achat d'attendre d'attendre les soldes
pour acheter beaucoup et en particulier
sur internet concernant les chiffres de
janvier on est en gros à quasiment 50 %
de plus que l'année dernière donc c'est
vraiment très impressionnant pour nous
en tout cas donc c'est bien au-delà de
la croissance du e-commerce qui je crois
que en 2013 était de de l'ordre de 10 15
% ben les gens sont sensibles
probablement en période de crise aussi
encore plus aux réductions qu'on
propose au sein des animateurs en charge
des tempséris scolair les profils sont
variés entre les titulaires qui ont pour
eux l'expérience du terrain les
contctuels ou les vacataires difficile
d'avoir une vision claire de ce statut
ces militants communistes demandent une
reconnaissance et une
professionnalisation de la filière qui
passe tout d'abord par une formation
minimale d'un BAFA et surtout préparer
ce personnel à la gestion
d'enfants que cette formation soit
reconnue c'estàdire qu'en fait qu'il
soit rémunéré
correctement comme cela va devenir
maintenant une une une fonction
structurée que ça devienne une filière
professionnelle autrement dit qu'on
puisse y faire carrière il va falloir
vraiment créer des formations
avec une compétence pédagogique
psychopédagogique également de façon à
faire la relation entre les activités
spécifiques qu'il représentent et les
les
activité purement scolaire de façon à ce
que justement il y ait une homogénéité
une complémentarité une
cohérence pour ces militants le thème de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires doit
intervenir dans le débat des élections
municipal ça doit intervenir dans le
débat municipal mais comme plein de
choses comme la question de la
démocratie globalement on touche à
quelque chose de fondamental pour les
parents quelque chose de fondamental
pour la République pour la République
aussi il y a une question il une
question d'égalité la question de de
l'accès pour tous à l'école et de la
réussite pour tous à l'école d'égalité
républicaine tout simplement dans le
cadre de la réforme le taux
d'encadrement d'un animateur pour 14
enfants de moins de 6 ans et deux pour
18 enfants de plus de 6
ans la semaine dernière sur notre
antenne le maire de saint-cier l'école
Bernard Debin exprimait son souhait de
voir son ancienne adjointe aujourd'hui
candidate revenir travailler avec lui
lors du prochain mandat c'est par un
communiqué que cette dernière vient de
lui répondre gaitane des jardin annonce
qu'il n'y aura aucune discussion avant
le premier tour sa liste se veut
indépendante de celle menée par l'UMP et
surtout elle refuse d'assumer le bilan
du maire candidat qu'elle qualifie de
mauvais en précisant sa pensée mauvaise
gestion du personnel échec de grands
projets et manque
d'éthique j'ai tellement peur de rater
le train que j'arrive à la gare avec TR
quart d'heure d'avance et je qu'estce
qu'elle croyait la
Parisienne accélérer le rythme le
ralentir autant d'exercices qui
permettent de gagner en assurance pour
lire à voix haute et devant tout type de
public pour la 3è année consécutive à
bois d'Arc la médiathèque de la tremblée
propose des stages de lecture sur un
weekend on découvre les mots on comprend
d'une sens on met en place plus on
ralentit plus on articule donc voilà
l'exercice mais et la vitesse
amène une assurance une une vitalité au
texte l'histoire se construit donc la
portant de la lenteur c'est que on donne
le temps à à l'imaginaire de se mettre
en place les voix sont différentes les
les forces de voix aussi les volumes de
voix donc du coup il faut jongler avec
ça surtout quand on lit à plusieurs
arriver à ce qu'une voix n'écrase pas
une autrece que voilà c'est surtout
là-dessus qu'on travaille là quand on
est en groupe habitué à parler en public
lors de ces cours de théâtre Nicole
s'est tout de même senti déstabilisé par
les exercices ce stage c'est aussi pour
elle
découvr des histo personnellement j'ai
découvert un texte magnifique que je ne
connaissais pas donc qui a déjà eu le le
plaisir le bonheur de la découverte et
effectivement les mots prennent un sens
différent presque différent de quand on
lit pour soi en fait lecteur compteur et
comédien Rémy profite de ce stage pour
se
perfectionner on
a tendance à à vouloir rester sur son
propre rythme
et je crois quand même que la lecture la
plus lente
est plus compliquée à maîtriser oui on
se concentre plus sur le mot en lui-même
que sur la phrase dans sa
totalité prochaine session prévu le
weekend des 1ers de février deux séances
de 3h sont proposées pour 35 €. on
m'accuse de cruauté c'est moi tout
craché ça c'est bizarre on avait pas vu
un chat de la matinée et vers 1h de
l'après-midi le défilé commence
qu'est-ce qu'elle croyait la Parisienne
on est arrivé qu'il a dit
Fabien les Beatles je que c'est toute
une génération du rock des années 60 70
et c'est un ouais c'est un phénomène
anglais qui a marqué une certaine
rupture avec la société des années 50 ça
représente P and love voilà les années
un petit
peu mais 60 68 ils ont révolutionné le
euh le monde de la chanson de des jeunes
en général le patrimoine du du rock and
roll c'est voilà ça fait partie de la
culture commune de l'histoire de la
musique et l'histoire du rock 1964 voici
50 ans les Beatles donnent leur premier
concert en France c'était à Versailles
au cinéma le Cano inconnu en France ils
faisaient leur début dans ce lieu
véritable antichambre de l'Olympia comme
le souhaitait à l'époque Bruno Cocatrix
mercredi soirée de commémoration de
l'événement avec un concert de jazz et
la projection de la comédie musicale
quatre garçons dans le vent rendez-vous
mercredi dè 18h dans la prochaine
édition du 78 lactu pour plus de détails
concernant ce spectacle juste avant le
lever de
rideau